-My next guest is
a Grammy winner
and a Tony-nominated actress
who stars in
the new HBO Max series
"Made For Love,"
which will begin streaming
new episodes tomorrow.
Please welcome Cristin Milioti!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Cristin Milioti ♪
♪ That's the girl
we're all thinkin' of ♪
♪ Cristin Milioti ♪
-You look great.
Welcome. Please.
-Thank you.
-That's it.
You've been on...
Thank you.
-Yeah.
-Thank you for
coming back to our show...
-Oh, my God, my pleasure.
-...and doing that silly sketch.
But, also, thank you for --
This is --
You're the only guest to be
in both studios.
-I know, yeah.
-Live in studio.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Oh, my God, it was my pleasure.
-Thank you.
-My pleasure.
It's so nice to see, like,
a full audience.
-Doesn't it feel great?
I want to talk about
"Made For Love,"
your HBO Max show.
It's getting great reviews.
Congrats on that.
That's awesome.
-Thank you, thank you.
-It's got to feel good.
I mean, we were
saying backstage,
because I saw a picture of you
in front of a giant billboard
in Times Square.
-Yeah.
-And you took a picture -- Or
who took that picture?
-My showrunner and I --
Christina Lee --
we went up to Times Square
because we heard
there was going to be a
billboard for like 45 minutes,
'cause it's electronic, so they,
like, switch through it.
And so we raced up with
sippy cups full of wine
to just, like, celebrate it.
-Yeah, that's what
it's all about.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I love this photo,
'cause I just love
anyone who's excited
and appreciative also,
but this photo I liked
almost even more,
'cause once you're in
Times Square --
-Yeah. You got to get
the characters in there.
-Times Square Elmo
and a couple of Mickey Mouses.
-And there's the Elmo,
there's the Mickey,
and then there's, like, the
Mickey that's, like,
on an off day,
going to the mall,
just, like,
wearing a coat with a purse.
-I love that Mickey's, like,
got a coat and a purse.
-But they kept being like,
"Well, You don't want --
No, you don't want
that poster in the back.
Like, here's the better angle."
And then we kept being like,
"Uh, we do, sorry."
-"Dude, that's
me," without saying that.
-Yeah, exactly.
But we were, like,
in front of it,
and we had our arms
around each other
and we were like,
"Wow, way to go.
Like, Man, what a journey."
And then we saw it
go like, "Beep!"
And we saw someone's laptop,
and they, like,
scrolled the pointer over
and, like, basic--
didn't throw it in the trash,
but, basically --
And it was a real, like --
the two of us standing there
being like, "Oh, show biz."
-Yeah, that's
show business right for you.
That's a very New York
kind of moment, right?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-You're a New Yorker. Sorry.
-I'm a New Yorker.
-Are you so happy
to see it coming back?
-So happy.
I just took the subway
for the first time.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-What was it like?
-It was beautiful.
I, like, put my, like,
subway music in,
and I, like, always am
blasting music on the subway.
And I almost started crying,
it was so beautiful.
Just that we were, like,
all back in there together.
-Yeah.
-But it wasn't --
I mean, obviously, it's not
at the level that, like --
I miss --
And I know we'll get back
to this, like,
the full, full, like, subway,
like, "I'm on a New York subway.
It's crowded."
-Yeah.
And some people are touching me.
-Some people are
touching me, yeah.
I would always try to
not touch the poles.
I would try to, like, surf,
which no one like.
-Oh! Dangerous.
-It's very rude.
I wouldn't do it now,
'cause when I was, like,
in my early 20s,
I'd be like, "I bet you I can't
touch the pole!"
I bet you I can."
And then I was like -- Yeah.
-Would you fall down?
-Yeah, one time,
I was headed to a rehearsal
and I had, like, a, you know,
big bagel and cream cheese
and I was, like,
trying to do that thing,
'cause it's, like, germs, too,
but also, like, I was like,
"I live here."
And I would, like, try to, like,
surf it, like, with the stop.
-Yeah.
-And so I would use like
one ankle bone
against, like, the thing.
And then I was, like, trying to
eat the bagel and cream cheese,
and they, like,
stopped short, and I fell,
but I was able to, like,
hold it up,
and I got it all over
my neck and hair.
But I was, like,
on my back, like, in the
grossest, like, stickiest
subway car.
But I was able to
save the bagel,
and then everyone applauded.
-That's New York!
-Yeah, I know.
-That is New York right there.
-That's New York. I know.
-That is New York.
-I'm very excited
to get back to that.
-Let's talk about
"Made For Love."
Congrats on the reviews,
but, also,
it's such a cool concept.
-Yeah.
-Is that what sold you on it?
-Yeah. I mean, when I read it,
I'd never read anything like it.
It's very hard to describe.
It's like --
-It's funny.
-Yeah.
-But it's sci-fi.
-And it's twisted.
-Yeah.
-Okay, good.
-Yeah. When I try to
describe it,
do you know that
YouTube video of, like,
the little boy
who's trying to describe --
He's trying to ask a question.
He's like, "Did you ever --
Did you see with the --
And you liked it so much that
you could do anything?"
Like, it's like that whenever
I try to describe it.
I'm like, "It's comedy
and it's also a survivor story
and it's also dark, it's also
twisted, it's also sci-fi.
Please just watch it."
But It's great. I love it.
I mean, I love it.
But it is like -- You know,
people might not trust you
if you're like, "Just trust me!
It's good."
-Oh, it works. It's good.
-But it does -- It has --
It's one of the things
I really loved about it is that
it had so many different genres
that I just hadn't ever seen
anything like that.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Cristin Milioti and
Ray Romano in "Made For Love."
Take a look at this.
-I need you to pay
a little more respect to Diane.
♪♪
It is what it is.
She's part of the family.
-Enlighten me on how this works.
Do you take a bite
out of her food
and then pretend
that she ate it?
Oh.
Is it ruined if I do it?
-Cristin Milioti!